now armenia has accused azerbaijan of
trying to advance into its territory
after fighting between the countries
broke out overnight armenia's prime
minister has phoned world leaders
demanding what he called an adequate
reaction
azerbaijan says its troops suffered
casualties in the border clashes while
armenia claimed several of its military
positions had been attacked
conflict between the two sites began in
the 1980s over the disputed region of
nagorno-karabakh
the ethnically armenian region is
internationally recognized as part of
azerbaijan
so we can cross to the armenian capital
yarivan where we join journalist maria
titian
who is monitoring events welcome maria
what's the current state of affairs
regarding this ceasefire
uh i don't know where you got the
information about a ceasefire there are
rumors but it has not been confirmed
that there is a ceasefire there is still
intermittent shelling
along the armenia azerbaijan border
after azerbaijani armed forces launched
a wide-scale attack uh
around midnight on september 13th
right
and there there have been um uh calls uh
from um to international uh actors to do
something to to act adequately have
those calls been met
uh with both sideism unfortunately uh
it's very important to stress that this
is not about the nagorno-gadapar
conflict this is azerbaijan attacking
sovereign armenian territory armenia
proper
in several
attacking not only military positions
but also physicians but also civilian
infrastructure in two regions of kerala
tunic and unique so this is this needs
to be separated from the art south issue
because this is an attack on a sovereign
country with recognized borders on the
seat of the united nations
so given that difference
what has prompted then this this uh
attack as as you as you term it given
that these tensions have been uh
bubbling um for for many decades now
and a deal was reached
why this
because uh
azerbaijan's president ilam alive after
the november 9 2020 ceasefire statement
that ended the 2020 arsakh war that had
lasted for 44 days and saw the loss of
significant armenian territory and the
loss of thousands of lives uh alive has
been insisting on creating a corridor uh
through armenia that would connect
azerbaijan with its explain in
makichavan this was not part of the
ceasefire statement
azerbaijan is now trying to
successfully attain this through the use
of force and because the international
community has allowed um a dictator like
alien to um
use force to get what he wants and and
not you know this
parody that they tried to say even with
last night's attack it was an unprovoked
attack on armenia and again
both sides are being asked to
de-escalate the situation right and so
given this this this both side-ism as
you call it from the international
community is this is this a conflict
that we need to pay more attention to
because as i say it's been going on for
20 odd years through various deals but
it never seems to go away
absolutely because this is not only
between armenia and azerbaijan we have
to understand that turkey which is a
very uh close ally a strategic partner
of azerbaijan and we know that
turkey has many problems with all of its
neighbors
has been
supporting azerbaijan
there are larger regional players in the
region there's iran there's turkey as i
mentioned russia these are players in
the region and given uh russia's
invasion of ukraine the shift in
geopolitical reality today in the
international order um this particular
conflict uh could be a tinderbox for a
much larger regional conflict on the
doors of europe
all right good talking to you thank you
for explaining that so clearly to us
that's journalist maria titian
in yerevan